[تصفيق]
في ركن من العالم لا تنقصه النزاعات وحروب
التصريحات اتهم رئيس منطقه ترانسنيستريا
الانفصاليه المواليه لروسيا اوكرانيا
بالوقوف وراء هجوم كان يستهدف مسؤولين
كبارا في المنطقه الاتهام جاء ساعات بعد
اعلان السلطات ترانسليا الواقعه بين
اوكرانيا ومولدوفا احباط هجوم قالت ان
الاجهزه الامنيه الاوكرانيه كانت تعتزم
فيه استهداف شخصيات بارزه في المنطقه
السلطات الاوكرانيه نددت بهذه الاتهامات
واعتبرتها استفزازا من تدبير الكرملين في
حين سبق لموسكو ان اعلنت نهايه الشهر
الماضي ان تحضر لمهاجمه المنطقه غير
المعترف باستقلالها دوليا ويخشى ان يقدح
هذا التوتر شراره حرب جديده حيث طالما
اعتقد الاوكرانيون ان روسيا ستعمد لتفعيل
جبهه ترانسنيستريا في اي لحظه الشريط
الرفيع الذي لا تتجاوز مساحته
4500 كيلومتر مربع
لا تتجاوز نصف مليون نسمه سبقا اعلنت
استقلالها من جانب احادي سنه واحده بعد
انهيار الاتحاد السوفيتي وتحتفظ فيها
موسكو بكتابه لحفظ السلام كما تقول
وبكميات كبيره من الذخائر ويخشى
الاوكرانيون من فتح جبهه اخرى لمهاجمه
مدينه اوديسا التي تقع بالقرب منها تصمت
موسكو امام هذه التطورات لكن واشنطن تراقب
المشهد من بعيد حيث اتهم منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في البيت الابيض جونكورربي
روسيا بمحاوله خلق تمرد في مولدوفا
متواعدا الروس بمزيد من العقوبات ووعد
المولدوفا بتقديم مزيد من الدعم